نحن هنا مع البحريه الامريكيه في هذه
المهمه مع الاصول الخامس تحديدا ننطلق
معهم عبر البحار لمتابعه ومراقبه كيفيه
وضعهم للمسيرات البحريه والجويه في مياه
مياه الخليج العربي دعونا انطلق
[موسيقى]
هي رفع الوعي في مجال السلامه البحريه عبر
نشر مسيرات او زوارق بحريه بدون قبطان في
البحار عبر استخدام الذكاء الصناعي نركز
على وضعي اكثر في البحر اذا استطعنا ان
نرى اكثر يمكننا ان نرفع مستوى المراقبه
وهو ما يجعل ذلك اكثر من الجميع
هنا اخي هذا الخليج في الخليج العربي
التحديدات الايرانيه كثيره من قرصنه
وتهريب اسلحه وتهريب مخدرات تحاول الفرقه
59 بالاسطول الخامس ان تقوم بنشر مسيرات
بحريه
وجويه وتحت البحار ايضا لاحباط عمليات
التهريب الكثيره التي تحدث هنا هويه ان
يصل الى نتيجه نهائيه تنهي كل التهديدات
الايرانيه المحتمله في هذه المياه
من الخليج العربي بديع يونس العربيه